oui bonjour bonjour à tous euh bon c'est
pas un bis répétitta que je vais faire
mais me tenaz à cœur en tout cas de de
partager avec vous ces quelques mots
chers citoyens Guillam mesdames et
messieurs il y a 7 mois nous étions tous
réunis ici pour trouver les bases d'une
dévolution statutaire qui permettra la
société guyanaise de prospérer je l'ai
dit il y a 7 mois et je le répète le
président d'ailleurs vient de le dire le
premier préalable à toute évolution est
notre capacité à travailler ensemble
notre capacité à faire société notre
capacité à mettre les intérêts de la
Guyane avant nos agendas politiques ce
jour-là mes paroles avaient suscité
l'étonnement puisque certains avaient ri
d'autres m'avaient critiqué face à la
dureté de mes propos mais beaucoup et
beaucoup d'entre vous m'aveent soutenu
car nous ne pouvons plus continuer à
nous cacher derrière les autres notre
responsabilité élu nous engage à nous
battre pour le bien-être de nos
populations rassurez-moi je ne suis pas
là pour annonner un discours d'il y a 7
mois je suis résolument tourné vers
l'avenir vers le devenir de notre chère
guyan les Guyanais attendent de nous les
élus et les responsables politiques que
nous soyons capables de trouver les
voies et moyens pour le développement de
notre pays nous devons être capable dès
aujourd'hui de trouver des accords sur
les résolutions qui nous seront sous ise
nous avons le devoir de montrer à l'état
que nous sommes capables de nous
entendre dans l'intérêt de la Guyane
avant de quitter cette salle de
délibération aujourd'hui nous devons
parvenir à une entente sur les contours
du projet guanais je me répète ce projet
doit nous ressembler et surtout nous
rassembler parvenir à un accord unanime
c'est aussi respecter le formidable
travail effectué par le COPIL mon agenda
ne me le permettait pas mais j'étais qui
était représenté par jean-y mirakov le
secrétaire général adjoint de nouvelles
forces de guyan et après chaque réunion
nous échangions sur la teneur des
rencontres parvenir à un accord c'est
aussi montrer à ceux qui nous épi que
nous savons être mature démontrer à ceux
qui nous promettent l'échec depuis des
décennies que nous savons aussi gagner
chers collègues chers amis je ne
souhaite pas être plus longue mais je
tenais à partager ces quelques mots avec
vous euh c'est un peu de la redondance
du discours du président qui a bien
compris qu'il faut que nous soyons tous
ensemble alors rentrant dans le vif du
sujet comme dirait mon collègue député
Jean-Victor castor
merci